- [Instructor] Where we
left off in the last video
we were in the year 656,
and the third caliph,
Uthman or Usman is assassinated,
and Ali is chosen to be caliph.
And remember, Shias believe
that Ali should have
been caliph immediately
after the death of Mohammed,
and they cite the events of Ghadir Khumm
as evidence that that is
what Mohammed intended.
But Ali becomes caliph in 656,
but this sparks what is
called the First Fitna,
or the first Muslim civil war.
Because Uthman has a fellow
member of the Umayyad clan,
the Umayyad clan, they're also Quraysh,
just like Mohammed's clan,
the Hashem are also Quraysh,
and Uthman's family member, Muawiya
was has-been governor of
Damascus since the time
of the caliph Umar, and
when Uthman is assassinated,
Muawiya is not happy, and
when Ali comes to power,
he thinks that Ali is
not making a solid effort
to put the assassins to justice.
And he refuses to pledge his allegiance
to Ali as the caliph, now
the other context here
is that Muawiya has
already built a significant
military force, and that force is becoming
stronger and stronger and stronger,
and so this leads to a lot of tension.
Muawiya wants Ali to bring
the assassins of Uthman
to justice, and Ali wants
Muawiya to pledge allegiance
to him, who is now caliph.
Now just for a little bit extra context,
Ali also decides to move
the capital of the caliphate
to Kufa, which is in modern day Iraq.
Now things are getting increasingly tense
and this is where we have Aisha entering
into the picture, and we talk about Aisha
in the previous video, she
is one of Mohammed's wives,
married at a very young
age, and she is considered
a very strong figure in early Islam.
So she leads a delegation, really an army,
in order to convince Ali to bring
the assassins of Uthman to justice.
The meet in Basra, once
again in modern day Iraq,
and while they're talking
about, or negotiating
what Ali needs to do,
some of Ali's followers,
as the narrative goes, were
a little bit more extreme
and really didn't want a peace brokered
between Muawiya and
Ali, and so they attack,
and that's what leads to what is known
as the Battle of the Camel,
which is depicted here,
named after Aisha's camel,
and it becomes a very bloody battle.
Aisha is really one of the
leaders in this battle.
Once again, you can imagine,
a very very strong figure
in early Islam, but Ali's
forces are victorious,
and they send Aisha back
home and then she goes
into something of a political retirement,
and it is somewhat inconclusive.
But then that leads
later on to what is known
as the Battle of Siffin, the
Battle of the Camel was in 656,
the Battle of Siffin is in 657,
and in this situation, you once again have
a delegation, or really
an army on the side of Ali
meeting an army directly
now with Muawiya at Siffin.
And once again, they are not fighting
for roughly 100 days, they
want to negotiate something,
but some of the more
ardent followers of Ali
don't want any form of peace with Muawiya,
so they attack Muawiya's army and you have
a very bloody battle that ensues.
Now both sides don't want
all of this bloodshed
in this burgeoning Muslim community,
so they decide to let it
be decided to arbitration.
Now the arbitration,
according to the accounts
that I've looked at, say that
they decided that neither
Ali or Muawiya should be caliph
and that it should be an election
from the Muslim community.
Now Ali refuses this, and
what's interesting about this
is the accounts I've seen is
that those same zealous folks
who you could say instigated
the Battle of Siffin
and the Battle of the Camel
during this Muslim civil war,
they're no longer trusting
Ali that he can protect them,
that he is the strong leader they need,
and so they are the ones that then decide
to assassinate, and are
successful in assassinating Ali.
So after the assassination
of Ali, his son, Hassan,
comes to power, officially as the caliph
based in Kufa, but remember,
you have this very powerful
leader in Muawiya with a
very significant military,
leading or in control of the Levant
and the governor of Syria.
And so they enter into a treaty,
clearly Hassan sees the
writing on the wall,
he can't really fight Muawiya
by force, he really
doesn't have strong control
really much further than
this region around Kufa,
so he gets into a treaty with Muawiya
where he gives control of
the caliphate to Muawiya,
and according to that treaty,
as long as Muawiya allows
the next caliph after
his death to be based
on some form of an election,
let the Islamic world
choose the successor afterwards.
But then later Hassan,
he goes into something
of a retirement, he dies in his mid 40s,
and some accounts say
that he was assassinated,
poisoned by his wife,
maybe due to the Umayyads
who didn't want him around,
and then in 680, Muawiya dies.
Now according to the treaty
between Muawiya and Hassan,
it should have been some
form of an election there,
but Muawiya says, or before his death,
he makes Yazid the successor.
And so Hussein, who is another son of Ali,
Hassan's younger brother, and
by this point Hassan is dead,
he says hey, this is a
breach of the treaty,
and does not pledge his
allegiance to Yazid.
But there is a group in Kufa who say hey,
we will support you, and
so Hussein goes to Kufa
but on the way there, and
he is with his family,
when Yazid catches wind of this,
he sends an army to stop
them, and Yazid's interest
is essentially to eliminate
Hussein and his family
so that you don't have any
other legitimate claimants
to the caliphate, especially
because, remember,
Hussein is a living
descendant of Mohammed.
And so you then have this
event where Yazid's forces
intercept Hussein's caravan in Karbala,
and this is known in the Shia tradition
as the Tragedy of Karbala,
because at Karbala,
you have Hussein's family gets massacred.
There is an account that
his six month old son
is beheaded and killed along with Hussein,
and so this becomes he defining
event of the Shia tradition,
the tragedy of Karbala, we've
already taught their belief
that Ali should have been the
caliph from the beginning,
but now you have Yazid,
proported caliph, who
murders, who kills off,
according to Shia tradition,
a significant member of Mohammed's family
and does this in bloody, bloody fashion.
And so even to this
day, a significant part
of the Shia tradition
is mourning what happens
at the Battle of Karbala,
and this is not a part
of the Sunni tradition, the
Sunni tradition views this
as a tragedy, as an unfortunate event,
but they do not view this
as a significant part
of their theology, and also
as part of Shia tradition
and theology, Battle of Karbala
is the determining event,
the thing that Shias mourn
in their religious faith,
and they also believe that the
leadership of the community
should be by imams who are
descendant of Mohammed,
which is not believed by the Sunnis.